an ohio couple says a mistake at a
hospital for turtley fertility clinic
rather more than 30 years ago has
changed their family forever
janine and mike harvey say a dna kit
recently revealed that their daughter
who is now 29
is not genetically related to her father
but to a stranger instead and they are
now suing alleging that the doctor and
the hospital that they trusted at the
time made a huge grievous mistake
consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner has been speaking with the
family
this is human lives we're talking about
the events that changed their lives mike
and janine harvey say began when they
went to an akron city hospital fertility
clinic back in 1991 for help getting
pregnant where dr nicholas spertos
performed an intrauterine insemination
the idea to inject her husband's sperm
directly into the uterus to increase the
chances of a pregnancy and soon after i
said i think we might be pregnant
daughter jessica arrived the next year
and grew up especially proud of her
italian heritage on her father's side so
much so she planned to visit italy with
her husband later this year to celebrate
her 30th birthday
my entire life i have always been so
passionate so proud of my heritage on
both sides
where i came from how my ancestors got
here
what makes me me today to help trace
relatives in italy she took an ancestry
dna test in december 2020 then got the
shock of her life the test comes back
i'm sitting at my desk at work actually
and i open it up and
i see some english there's irish welsh
german
like where's the italian maybe it's
sicilian with what nothing she says the
test showed no connection to her father
my stomach just dropped and i knew
something was i knew something was wrong
from the get-go and she says another
test from labcorp confirmed it the
probability that her father was actually
her father the test report said zero
percent well it really didn't seem real
i mean how can this be i was in the
delivery room i'm like wait a minute
i carried a total stranger's child
you know for nine months
and
who in the world
does this other half of this child
belong to the harvey's are now suing the
suma health system and dr speartose
saying the doctor actually injected
sperm from a different man who the
complaint says along with his wife was
undergoing fertility treatments with the
same doctor at the same time as the
harveys the family's attorney adam wolf
it shouldn't be that the fertility
clinic transferred some stranger sperm
into mrs harvey's body that is not okay
it's not okay under the law it's not
okay under any sense of medical ethics
and it shouldn't happen ever
dr spertos did not respond to our
request for comment assume a health
system spokesperson said in a statement
we take this allegation seriously and
understand the impact this has on the
family at this point we have not met
with the family or conducted testing of
our own professor dove fox who directs
the university of san diego's center for
health law policy and bioethics says
these cases can be tough to win in court
courts tend to say something like you
wanted a kid you got a kid
even a healthy one so what are you
complaining about how are you
worse off than you otherwise would have
been fox says 24 states have bans on
suing over wrongful births he believes
there should be a way for parents to sue
over problems with procedures like
fertility treatments even if a healthy
child is born as for the harveys they
want change it's almost a gamble and it
shouldn't be you shouldn't be gambling
when you're creating
a human being a life
in its statement suma health system said
it has very limited information and that
given the amount of time that has passed
it remains our hope that the attorneys
representing the family will work with
us to make that next step a priority
that's in reference to meeting with the
family and doing their own round of
testing now you might wonder about
jessica harvey galloway's biological
father she has spoken with him she says
he told her he was pleased to have a
child that he'd gone his entire life
thinking he had not had any children and
he told her he now tony has a daughter
wow that's good news for him but anna mr
harvey the father she grew up with does
he know if he has another child out
there somewhere or that part of the
story is unclear
that's part of the mystery here they
don't know what happened to his sperm
that he provided that was supposed to be
used with his wife
so the answers aren't there and that's
another question that they have
obviously is was his sperm used for
somebody else's procedure yeah
wow and what a powerful story it's
upsetting all the way around in mr fox's
assessment of well you you wanted a
child you got a child what's the problem
i can think of a whole lot of problems
well he's saying the courts would say
the courts would say i can't imagine a
judgment there and making a remark like
that but we'll see anna thank you very
much very eye opening story there